loads of people who are very supportive
of trans ideology have no particular
skin in this game they just decided that
this is the latest virtue single it's
the latest way to be a good person they
might be very attached to the idea of
themselves as somebody who back in the
day would have been you know part of the
Civil Rights Movement would have been
for fighting for women's suffrage would
have you know been really campaigning
for gay marriage but those things are
done you want something to do so you
become quite attached to this
and then anyone who says to you but look
you know if you allow men to be women
over here
you're going to have rapists in women's
jails over there you're going to ruin
women's sport you get very angry yeah
and you must silence people it's the
only way to maintain the LIE is to let
it is to make it impossible for anyone
to talk about it that's why it's
totalitarian you have to control the
language you have to keep people silent
you have to cancel anyone who says
anything about it in order that other
people are too scared to speak about it
that's why because it's a lie